you might be surprised to learn that I
have only been to one other wedding it's
actually a very cute story my mom was
marrying Jeff and they asked me to be
ring bearer and I was understandably
emotional and somehow my pants became
wet long story short Jeff's dog ended up
as a ring bearer and the irony is that
after the ceremony that dog peed on
everything
[Music]
that's way dress
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
me walking Phyllis down the aisle was
supposed to be the highlight of the
wedding and now the wedding has no
highlight
[Music]
I can't believe I pushed that that guy's
lazy ass around all day until he was
ready to stand up and steal the show
that's well I Got News for You Albert
that's your real name shows not over
[Music]
[Applause]
and now for my old hometown Scranton
Pennsylvania my former boss Michael
Scott
hey I just think you should know that
one of my salesmen beat your stupid
computer so take that out to forget
something what happened to you guys give
it back give it back what is this it's
real simple
if you don't appreciate what we do then
give us back our basket maybe you should
leave you should maybe you should leave
come on let's leave but before we leave
my wet friend and I are gonna wait for
our nice I'm sorry
look my clothes are so wet wet nice
leather shoes are so muddy oh yeah it
was mine what's missing Christmas ooh
you've been a very naughty girl I see
Michael we already have a Santa Phyllis
what the hell is going on come on I need
this come over here talking just sit
down okay
what you can't yell out I need this I
need this as you pin down an employee on
your lap okay you know what Jim two
Santa's in the room
things get ruthless you understand you
forced my hand Michael it's Phyllis we
want to assess Anna Oh do we do we is
that what we want why don't we take a
vote on it great Hey
okay everybody the office is being
pulled apart I realize that there are
traditions at stake
there who wants votes no no no wait no
there are other choices there's
information that we are you kidding me
Kevin after you almost killed me
Michael I had you I just want to try
Phyllis and if you want Michael is Santa
raise your hand I get you some punch
yes just arrived from the dunder mifflin
North Pole branch we don't have a North
Pole branch idiot self a friend you've
been very good this year
yeah except for cheating on your wife
doctors are sin look it up the Bible
people what do you get God
scented candles oh well that's
appropriate a lot of fire where you're
going better get used to it you're going
to AG ll double hockey sticks going to
hell Stanley and this brings us to you
that a one I can't see from here people
somebody shout it out don't make me get
up it's fabric I really wanted this
that's fantastic you make another dress
that goes past your feet Andy is this
you this is all right it was a severe
that Michael you whoa they're not
supposed to stay what turn it back on
No
that's at least four red chips to user
all in bluffing is a key part of poker
which is too bad because I'm not very
good at bluffing did you believe me what
art that's insane good cars well Toby I
went all-in on the first hand so doesn't
that tell you that I might have good
cards too so don't be stupid just take
it back
I'm sorry cancer is going on okay right
whatever flip them you really
[Music]
yeah and now a man who deserves no
introduction Michael Scott thank you
very much thank you that was great great
job some great laughs really really went
after my intelligence there ah dozens of
online IQ test might prove you wrong but
and my thing isn't tiny its average so
get your facts straight
um so when I heard that there was going
to be a roast in my honor
I thought froggy Mike I decided to jot
down some quick thoughts about you
people
first up Phyllis Kevin
[Music]
well I'm sorry if it seems that way to
you okay that might help if you said I'm
sorry in front of everybody my front of
me you made a bad call and I fixed it so
I'm not apologizing so that's it that's
it is it yes yeah can you vote for other
pair hey it's cool man I work in the
warehouse I'm cool I'm hip and I'm John
but I don't care about nobody Do You
Know Who I am happy Halloween jerk
still don't know who I am I'll give you
a hint I go over other people's heads
Michael this is a bad idea
what's a bad idea dressing up as
somebody I mean when has that ever
worked for you never okay you know what
fine
I'm not Darryl I thank God I'm not
Darryl could you for once just let us
enjoy a party instead of making it a bet
all your excuse
you